lady gaga's dog walker ryan fisher is
speaking out for the first time since
being shot while walking her dogs
he shared these pics and wrote four days
ago while a car sped away
and blood poured from my gunshot wound
an angel trotted over and laid next to
me
my panicked screams calmed as i looked
at her even though it registered that
the blood
pooling around her tiny body was my own
i cradled asia as best i could thanked
her for all the incredible adventures
we'd been on together
apologized that i couldn't defend her
brothers and then resolved that i would
still try to save them
and myself it was all so fast literally
in
20 sec 30 seconds i looked over i saw
the car doors open
i saw the guy screaming and there was
something there
couldn't tell it was so fast to be
honest with you and that's when i heard
the gun shot and i ran back in the house
jumped on the floor told my partner
everyone get on the floor called 9-1-1
immediately and a second gunshot ryan
was walking gaga's three french bulldogs
at the time
of the attack gustav koji and asia
the most important thing is someone got
shot and could be dead right now
i mean i feel bad for the dogs we need
to get those dogs out but someone
actually got shot over
dogs in his post he says he is still in
recovery from quote a very close call of
death
he absolutely was trying to protect
those dogs i mean
absolutely he would literally lay down
his life for any one of our dogs
and i certainly hope that that was not
the case this time
brian you will make it ryan says he
plans to say more later but that he is
grateful for all the support and that
the police helped to return
koji and gustav safely of course ryan
also thanked his family
his friends and lady gaga adding quote
your babies are back and the family is
whole
we did it you have shown so much support
throughout this whole crisis to both me
and my family but your support as a
friend despite your own traumatic loss
from your kids
was unwavering i love you and thank you
is there any message that you want to
give him that you're hoping to get to
him
yeah and just like ryan we love you
remington loves you
all of the dogs love you please please
please pull through this
oh my gosh i'm so sorry this is i i
i can't imagine um what this must be
like for you
how are you doing good i mean yeah i
mean i just can't
believe that this is what the world has
become it's really sad
over the weekend the singer's rep
confirmed to et that gaga's stolen
frenchies had been returned
it is unknown if the person received the
500 000
reward money gaga offered during the
search